speaking of human girlfriends
um I'd love your advice in this
direction but you're you have an amazing
relationship with uh kalila yeah uh so
you two are very different so you host
the tiger Bella podcast together but
there's there's real love there there's
a there's a real connection what do you
um what do you love most about kalila
let's talk about love Bobby Lee yeah
yeah I mean that's a really pretty deep
I've never really gone down this path
um we're gonna walk down that path
together holding hands it's one of those
things where the first time I met her
it was almost as if I had known her all
my life it was really weird you know I
mean there was a
a trust there you know I mean that was
just fundamentally there that I could
trust her and that I could you know
when I look in the mirror and I see all
my Character defects and stuff though a
lot of those things aren't necessarily
things I want to share with people
because I don't want to be judged or
ridiculed but with her I felt
comfortable showing those things and I
think she feels the same way about her
and then secondly she's funny
I mean she made me laugh and and she's
hot it's all you know I mean the perfect
it was like a perfect combination of
things you know I mean she one night we
were in bed and I forgot what the joke
was but she really made me laugh one
night it was she was living in an
apartment in Long Beach and I cackled
you know what I mean and generally women
don't make I mean not women I'm dating
Comics do
um don't make me cackle in that way and
then um thirdly she has
um
she's partly Asian
so it's like you know one time I dated a
white girl yeah and I invited her to
Koreatown you're about to be racist a
little bit okay yeah yeah and what I
love about Asian girls is they'll eat
something first and ask what it is after
but white girls ask what it is before
what is this right but Clio would eat
the eyeball eat everything go what did I
just eat I like that you know what I
mean so it's like and it reminds me of
my mom in that way in terms of like my
mom growing up just
scare us and freak us out we'd have a
fish and she would eat the eyeball first
to see a squirm and as a kid that you
thought was gross and weird and this and
that but it's like
you know when kalila does it it just
kind of like I don't know it just makes
it makes me feel like at home yeah in a
weird way I don't know it's a it's a
little Act of fearlessness I like that
yeah just put in your mouth and figure
it out yeah that's what I like
and at the end of the day she also out
of all my girlfriends and I this is
gonna sound
not strange but um hard to admit but
my career when I met kalila was in the
[ __ ] box
I could not get anything going and um
this is at the time where
Ken Jeong who's a very good friend of
mine very talented was getting
everything and I just remember going I
can't even get an audition like I can't
I would go on the road Lex and I would
fill half the room
I just couldn't sell tickets and when I
met her I was just kind of like maybe
this is the I had to find love and open
up my world in that way and she was the
first girlfriend that ever had that
looked at me and saw the potential and
she said no this is not doesn't feel
right you're so funny and you're so
relevant to me and this is what we're
gonna do and so she started tigerbelly
you know and then
um obviously I had a skill set to do it
um but once tiger belly happened and
then Andrew was like let's do bad
friends and then
now things are great you know my career
is
I'm too busy almost in a weird way you
know and I feel like she had a lot to do
with like for instance before I met her
even if I would get an audition I
wouldn't go because I just wouldn't get
it in my head I was like I'm not gonna
get this I've gone on a thousand of
these and they just never hire me but
she was so I just didn't go on on them
for years and then she was the first
girlfriend that said no
I don't care if you don't get it right I
just want you to be a [ __ ] and I want
you to walk through fear and so she
would drag me to these [ __ ] things
and I for some reason would book them
you know what I mean so
you know in that we saw the potential of
what you could be but she loved you for
who you are already yes but also loved
you for the potential that you could
become yeah and I'm lucky in that way
you know so on day one you could show
her you said you could show her your
flaws to her like you felt like you
could be Fragile with her well I
accidentally farted yeah or day one on
day one yeah you know because I just had
I'm a fart machine yeah and I have loose
cheeks yeah I like how you work for the
listeners he just winked at me yeah I
have loose cheeks and um but not in a
gay way not in a Gateway no and I um I
was wearing a couch and we're talking
and I kind of adjusted my body I ripped
one by accident
as she laughed you know I mean it wasn't
embarrassing you know and um
let's have a little penis I have a
little penis and it's all relative yes
it's a little
but relative to an elephant everybody's
penis is yeah but I'm not an elephant
I'm a human you know what I mean so
relatively human is it's very small okay
and so when she saw it you know I mean I
thought she was gonna bark at it yeah
right and she looked at it as if it was
like an orphan
like how you know like I wanna you know
it's a lost child and I wanna you know
you know take care of it yeah yeah
cradle it a cradle yeah
well you man you you haven't met anybody
like that uh never met a girl never seen
one of them I hear they're nice
winner what are the two you getting
married
we don't know yet yeah is that something
you would like yeah
um this comes up sometimes you know
we're in couples counseling we're
dealing we're working on some issues
that we have sure every relationship
even my friendships have issues
and so we're working through some issues
and once we get to the end of it we'll
figure it out